- On this episode, we go
live on YouTube it crashes,
we go on Instagram and
we have an epic ending.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions
and I answer them
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Before we get
into this episode,
we should take advantage,
yeah do that too,
maybe a little bit there,
we should take advantage of
of everybody being here, how
do we gamify subscriptions
for YouTube
with all these peeps?
- [Andy] The bell.
- The bell?
(bell dings)
What bell?
They see a bell?
- [Andy] There's a
level of you subscribe
where you need to hit
the bell notification.
- The notification.
- [Andy] Yeah.
- So if they're watching
right now there's a bell
that they fucking see?
- [Andy] Let me.
- Show it to me.
Guys hit the fucking bell.
(bell rings)
- [Andy] Levion Bell.
- Not the Levion Bell.
I hate the fucking Steelers.
Alright start putting
your phone numbers in here.
Hey everybody,
Hannah great to see you.
Great to see you
Z Brent, Aneesh Tyler.
- [Andy] See how
there's this bell here?
- Alright yeah, so they're
watching and hit the bell.
- [Andy] I'll turn on.
- Turn on the bell.
So are they, show me how you're
watching this live right now.
Right so you're
watching, is the?
Oh good, guys, there's a bell.
- [Andy] Lower right corner.
- Oh look.
They're seeing me this way
but if I go this
way will it switch?
There we go.
Nope.
So this is how
it's showing live, like,--
- [Andy] Yeah.
- With all that black?
What the fuck's up with that?
That's just how it rolls huh?
Like I can't go, like.
- [Andy] But if you go.
- Yeah if I go like that
it just, it does this shit.
See?
- [Andy] Yeah it's coming back.
- Okay we're going to figure
out this YouTube Live thing
great to see you, thank
you to everyone who's hitting
the likes up here,
please do but more importantly
there's a bell down
there, everybody, all of you,
please hit the fucking bell.
(bell dings)
Alright keep putting
up Mattie Anne Slathe,
Gonzalo you
putting down the bell?
Tom, Dillon, you
hitting the bell?
TM hitting the bell?
Andrew Mathison good to see you.
Sergeant, Sergeant Jeremy Reese,
USA baby, USA.
Alright let's do it,
their phone numbers are rolling.
- [Andy] Okay.
- I don't know how
you're going to stop them,
they're rolling fast.
I'm going to switch the script
in getting to this show.
There you go, Sean.
You can flip it around.
You're good.
Alright episode what?
244?
Ready?
- [Andy] Yep.
- Cool.
Hey everybody
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 244
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
And we are live on YouTube
flipping the
script a little bit,
excited about that.
And ready to roll.
Going to go to the call-in show
which is always a lot of fun.
I especially like when I hold
it and get a little excited
about that.
We should put on the lights.
Let's see here, yep.
Hope everybody's super well.
Great weekend, I'm
heading out to the west coast
before this monster storm.
We got a blizzard
coming boys and girls.
And it looks like
Andy K is on his game.
Big upgrade from Chris A
with his calling it.
Listen, Chris was
struggling with calling.
- [Operator] The
number you have dialed.
Oh!
- I spoke too soon And.
Alright, I'll talk a little bit
while you get
your shit together.
First of all, just want
to thank everybody for all
of the love I've been getting
across all of social YouTube,
hit the bell, hit the bell.
(bell dings)
Instragram all this stuff trying
to put out a lot of content.
DailyVee's been rolling.
Tyler doing a really good job.
Where's DRock?
Is he working today?
- [Other Tyler] He's in Chicago.
(phone ringing)
Why traveling?
Sleeping in Chicago?
- [Tyler] Sleeping in.
- What?
Alright let's get into the show.
(phone ringing)
- [Nick] Hello?
- Hello this is Gar Vaynerchuk
and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Nick] Get the
fuck outta here.
- Uh-huh, what's your
name because I'm presuming
it's not Nicole?
- [Nick] Nah, nah,
nah, it's Nick Rizzo.
- Nick, how are you?
- [Nick] Good man how you doing?
- Great man,
what's your question?
- [Nick] Ah shit,
so I guess I was,--
- So Nick real quick,
since everybody does this,
will use this
opportunity to like,
what everybody's just
putting their phone number
and they just never think it's
actually gonna get called,
right?
- [Nick] Well so Nicole
is my wife's little sister
and I got her
on to watching you,
she's been watching
all of your stuff
and I guess she
just put my number
and she just texted me saying,
hey I just put your number.
(group laughter)
- Oh so this is even better.
Andy redemption for you.
- [Nick] Holy shit.
- Well good man, well
thanks for being on the show.
Great job by her, do you
have a business question,
or any kind of question?
- [Nick] So I am starting
to build my own business
I've had one I'm transferring
over the brand name
into something I'm
more passionate about
more easier for me
to truly make content
I really care about and
make a business I care about.
I guess one
question I would have is--
- Real quick I'm going to
stop you there before you go
to your question as
you gather your thoughts
for everybody who's watching,
my man here drilled it, because
he said it would be easier
for me if I was
passionate about it.
And I think the
big key on Crush It!,
you should show that,
is the reason I talked about
cashing in on your passion
is when you love it,
like if I had to talk
about the Jets 24 hours
a day, piece of cake.
I love attention and marketing.
Piece of cake, business.
If Tyler right over
here, had to talk about
the Penn State Lions he
could do it all day, right?
He's struggling with his
transition to a Jets fandom.
He did a
terrible job transitioning
into fantasy baseball
fandom so it's harder for him
even though he wanted to and
all his boys were doing it
it wasn't his passion,
it is a lot easier to create,
document, hustle, DM,
biz dev, win,
when it's subject matter
that you're interested in.
If you're getting into real
estate but you're not interested
in real estate
or flipping homes,
but that's where
you heard the money was,
or if you're starting
a social media agency
but you're doing it
because that's where
you think the money is and
it's not something you love,
you're gonna lose 'cause
you're not going to put in
enough hours to win because
you don't love it, right?
- [Nick] Preach, brother.
I've been trying to
build something that got into
for like six months and
I just was going nowhere.
When you sit down
and do work everyday
and it's like a bore and you
don't want to get into it.
It's,--
- Did you get into it,
did you get into it
because you thought
that's where the money was?
- [Nick] It was a supplement
company I started doing
the research and
development for products for
back when I was in college
and then I kinda became
the owner and the
guy handed it down to me.
- Got it.
- [Nick] And it just
wasn't moving forward
the way I wanted to so
now I'm changing over things.
- Good what's the question?
- [Nick] I guess specifically,
what is, per value wise
do you see a lot of value
in utilizing Facebook
community groups to kind
of offer free courses
and things like that
to target specific niches,
do you think a Facebook group
would be a beneficial way
to host that or?
- Yeah I'm actually a,
good job by you
because I haven't talked
a lot about Facebook groups
in a long time and I'm
actually pretty big fan of it.
I think building community
on Facebook is very smart,
closed groups can
be very attractive.
Yeah, I'm a big fan of groups,
I think it builds community,
I think if you're
going to build a group bro,
you just got to make a
commitment to be in the group.
Ot's like 2003 forums, right?
If you're going to build a
forum on the internet in 2002
it was a good idea.
It was a good idea in 2006.
Problem is you gotta be in it.
You gotta be in there right?
- [Nick] Post a lot--
Exactly, just like 4chan
all the way back did well
'cause Moot was in it.
Like you gotta be in it, right?
Jets Insider did well
because Brian was in it,
like if you're gonna host,
if you're gonna build a
community don't think
somebody else is going
to run it for you,
or like it's gonna
take care of itself,
you've got to manage it.
You gotta live in it
and provide value.
- [Nick] Yeah, I'm just
trying to use that as a place
where I can build a community
for people to feel safe
and to feel a part of
to kind of grow together
as a group itself too so.
- I think it's a good place,
man.
Thanks for your call.
- [Nick] Thank you very much.
Have a great day.
- Take care, bye bye.
Pretty good.
Yeah, I think
communities really matter,
I think there's a
lot of ways to do them,
I think GroupMes and WhatsApps,
and closed Facebook
groups, email newsletters,
internet forums,
yeah, I mean I think,
walled gardens,
closed environments,
for a group to build together
is a really rad thing to do.
What's up?
- [Andy] A.J. from
the Arctic Circle.
- A.J. It's Gary Vaynerchuk
from The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [A.J.] Oh my God,
I knew you were gonna call,
I don't know why,
I just knew it.
- You knew it today, man.
- [Andy] He said Arctic Circle.
- I love it man.
Well listen, you
should play the lotto tonight.
- [A.J.] Dude,
we gotta be quick.
I'm literally in
the Arctic Circle,
I only get service outside.
It's -42. So.
- Jesus. Let's do
this before you die.
(group laughter)
- [A.J.] Hey man,
my question is,
my family,
they don't operate like I do.
They don't work as hard as I do.
I want to help them,
but my friends think
that they're, they're drowning
me, you know what I mean?
- I see, you're
carrying your family's weight
on your shoulders,
the family business?
- [A.J.] Yeah. Yeah.
- This is tough
bro, because, listen,
I've been a driving
force in two family businesses,
where, you just gotta, honestly,
this is a very personal answer,
everybody's gotta
make their own decision.
It depends on what you
value, and what feels good,
and that will go up and down,
it feels good for me what I
brought to the partnerships
to my brother and
dad, and at times,
it didn't feel good.
I mean, it's,
you know, it's hard,
when you're hustling harder.
But you can't also,
like I can't expect
AJ to do
exactly what I'm doing,
because I'm being selfish.
I'm doing it for myself.
And so I think
- [A.J.] Yeah.
- You need to be, you know,
it's easy for
everybody from the outside,
saying yo bro, stop
carrying your sister
and your uncle and
everybody's getting money
off your back, if
it makes you feel good,
and you're okay
with 15 cents on a dollar
or 50 cents on a dollar,
well that's your life.
So, I would say this,
if you've got a problem with it,
and your friends
are saying that because
they're supporting what you're
saying after four beers,
that's one thing.
But if they're just
observing from the outside,
and they're starting
to change your mind,
I wouldn't let outside sources
tell you what to do
with inside a family dynamic.
- [A.J.] Okay.
I mean, I've been
struggling for years,
so this is great,
I do appreciate it.
- I appreciate it.
Is there anything I
can help build on this?
'Cause I think
family business is a place
where I have a lot of expertise
and a lot of experience,
and I pay attention to it.
Can I build on this for you
before you freeze to death?
- [A.J.] You know what,
you've talked about this
kind of a lot, not
necessarily this specific case,
but this really, like, solves
a lot of questions for me,
so, I'll just keep
watching your content,
and I'm sure you'll
talk about it again later.
- Good man.
If I can ever help
you again, let me know.
- [A.J.] Hey
man, I appreciate it.
Thanks for calling dude.
- You got it. Bye-bye.
Let's level
that up for everybody
while Andy gets the next number.
Listen.
You have to be very
careful and very smart
if you're getting
feedback from your inner circle
of people that
love you, 'friends',
about things,
based on you talking,
and then reacting
and supporting you,
versus them
observing from the outside
and imposing their own
family dynamics onto you.
It's super important.
You take a step back and realize
what's happening, what's
the chicken and egg here.
Is this people responding to me,
or is this me getting
advice from people
that just don't
know how exactly I feel,
or every little part
about it inside my world.
Sean, you playing
with, what's goin on,
you answering people? You okay?
- [Sean] No, I'm just
trying to get the video back.
- What happened?
- [Sean] You got a call,
and when
I declined it, it came back.
- Let me see.
That sucks. Let's see.
That's, why did I,
reconnect.
(phone ringing)
I think we're good.
- [Audrick] Hello?
- [Andy] Audrick.
- Hey man, it's Gary Vaynerchuk
and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Audrick] That
is freakin' awesome.
What's going on Gary?
- Life is really good, my man.
What's your name?
- [Audrick] Hey, my
name is Audrick McGarow.
- I'm not sure
if it's recording, but.
Audrey, I want to
make sure I heard that.
What's that?
- [Audrick] Audrick.
Audrick McGarow.
- Audrick. Real,
real pleasure man.
How are you?
- [Audrick] I'm
doing excellent, man.
Hey Gary, definitely, you've
been an inspiration to me,
and a couple
things that you have told
in some of your
things about not actually
creating the stuff,
but actually documenting,
has been a turning
point in what I've been doing.
- Makes me happy.
- [Audrick] So I started,
yeah, I started
a Facebook ad agency,
to try to help people
with their Facebook ads.
But my true passion has been
in motivational speaking.
You know, so I
started documenting videos
on my Instagram, and in a short
time I've been able to reach
people with my words, and
the reason I find my passion
is in the fact that I
want to be able to reach people
that I didn't have in my life,
because I was growing up
through my obstacles. Correct?
- I get it.
- [Audrick] My question
to you is,
how do I expand,
so that I can
actually reach more people,
actually be more impactful,
other than documenting my life
and actually
speaking from the heart?
You know, 'cause right
now, I'm growing organically
on my Instagram.
- How long have
you been doing it?
- [Audrick] So I actually
started about two weeks ago.
And I know that it's gonna
take some time to grow more.
- Dude.
- [Audrick] But just
wanted to know what other tips
I can do, to be
able to reach that point
where I'm reaching more people.
- Put out content where
people are paying attention.
Facebook, YouTube,
Instagram, Snapchat,
blogs, podcasts,
and put out content.
- [Audrick] Okay.
- And dude, when I tell you
that when I start something,
I don't even
begin to think about
how many more people I can reach
than I've been reaching,
maybe I start
caring at year three,
maybe the first time
I even think about it,
is three years into a decision.
You just told me that
you found your passion,
that you're a
motivational speaker,
and you're antsy.
Say whatever you
want, but you are.
You're antsy two
weeks in to get bigger.
That's gonna be a
disaster formula, my man.
You need to put your head down,
and you have to understand.
How many followers
you got on Instagram?
- [Audrick] I've grown up
to 302 in the two weeks.
- I love it.
You need to be in a place
where if nine months from now
you're at 413,
you're feeling just as good.
- [Audrick] Uh-huh.
- You're feeling just
as good. You know why?
- [Audrick] Ah, definitely.
- You know why,
though, I'm telling you that?
- [Audrick] Why's that?
- Because by the way,
I have a funny feeling,
my man, that if you
were at 413 followers
nine months from today,
you would not be happy.
You went from zero
to 320 in two weeks,
why the fuck would you
only gain 100 followers
in eight months
and two weeks, right?
The reason that
you should be thrilled
if you're at 419 in nine months,
is you just told me
you found your passion.
- [Audrick] Yeah.
And that's the
biggest thing that I,
'cause I know that
it's gonna take time.
And that's one thing that I,
you know,
I'm 35 years old, and freakin'--
- You're a kid.
- [Audrick] Yeah, exactly.
I'm still young, like you.
- You're real young, man. 35?
You got your
whole life ahead of you.
- [Audrick] And
that's the biggest thing,
I want to make sure that
one, you know,
watching your content
has definitely humbled me a lot,
to wanting to be the rich guy.
I don't want to be the rich guy.
I wanna be the guy
that people reach out to me,
and tell me hey, because of you,
I see things differently.
I'm more positive.
You know, and that's really what
my ultimate goal is going to be.
- My man, if you believe that,
and I actually
weirdly believe you,
then I'm gonna tell
you the number one thing
that you have to figure out.
Patience and humility.
- [Audrick] Okay.
- Do not wrap
your self-esteem up
into the number
of followers you got.
- [Audrick] Gotcha.
- You got 310 people
on earth that fucking
give a fuck about
what you have to say,
and you can change
every one of those lives,
you'd leave a
bigger impact on this earth
than 99% of people.
- [Audrick] That's deep.
- It is deep.
So be happy you got 310,
instead of worrying
about getting 3,000.
- [Audrick] Okay. Will do.
Yo, thank you
for calling me, man,
- You got it, man.
Good luck to you.
- [Audrick] Alright. Thank you.
- Cool. Take care.
We're on Instagram Live now
'cause YouTube crashed.
- [Sean] YouTube crashed, okay.
I was trying to figure it out.
- Yeah, YouTube crashed.
Let's get one or two more calls
before I got my next meeting.
Guys, you know,
everybody wants to grow.
Everybody wants to
continue to succeed, I get it.
But boy do I wish
I could, like, look at my world,
I was on Instagram
for fuckin' five years
and was at like
40,000 followers.
Like it's not about
the following count.
Your time will come
if you're good enough.
If you're a good
enough motivational speaker,
or good enough executive
or good enough designer,
good enough entrepreneur,
you're time will come.
Everybody's in a rush.
- [Andy] Taylor.
- Right?
(phone ringing)
Everybody's in
a rush to grow up.
I wish I was 12
and throwing a ball.
- [Taylor] Hello?
- Hey Taylor, it's GaryVee.
You're on The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Taylor] No way!
- Yes way.
- [Taylor] Holy crap.
Okay.
- Where you from?
- [Taylor] Yeah, sweet.
I'm from Buffalo, New York.
- I love it,
are you a Bills fan?
(Taylor sighs)
- [Taylor] Unfortunately yes.
- I know you said unfortunately
'cause you're trying--
- [Taylor] We're not doing good.
- Well listen, neither
are the Jets, don't worry.
So what's going on?
(Taylor laughs)
- [Taylor] Nothing much.
I basically was just
dying to ask you a question.
Currently graduated
college last May
and I'm trying to
build my own business,
brand, hustle,
all that kinda stuff.
My question for you
is, and I'm probably sure
that a lot of people ask this--
- It's okay.
- [Taylor] The same things.
- [Taylor] How do you get over
the stump of you're
graduating, and you feel
all this pressure
'cause you're trying
to build something
but you're still so young.
But you wanna do the
stuff and grow it big.
I'm just in a rut and
I can't get out of it.
But I have a hustle and a drive
that I know I'll be
able to build something.
But I'm just in this
space that's not--
- I know where you're at.
- [Taylor] That's not
allowing me to.
- Let me help you.
The space you're in is
probably the macro, micro issue.
So it's macro patience,
micro speed, right?
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- What do I mean by that?
You need to be
patient as fuck, Taylor.
You're 22, 23-years-old.
Like what do you
think's gonna happen overnight?
- [Taylor] Yeah, I know.
- You need to be fast.
7 A.M. to two in
the morning every day.
But in the big picture, you
need to realize nothing good
is gonna happen
for the next six years.
- [Taylor] Okay.
Do you think that I should just
try every good idea that I think
I have and just
go for it all out?
Or do you think I should stick
with one thing at a time?
- I think the fact that you even
asked that question,
that you should
taste flirting with a
lot of different things
because you'll be crippled
by the what if if you don't.
Even though
that's not the perfect
formula to build the
biggest short term wealth
because you should
triple down on one thing
instead of being
half pregnant on nine.
- [Taylor] Okay, I like that.
- Taylor, let me
tell you something.
Let me ask you, the
pressure, who do you?
Like are you trying
to prove to yourself,
to your siblings, to
your parents, to the world?
Who are you trying to prove that
you're successful to,
or that this
was the right call,
or you're gonna make it?
That's what you
have to figure out.
- [Taylor] Hmm,
that's a good question.
- What are you impatient for?
What's the problem?
You wanna buy a fuckin' Rolex?
What's the rush?
- [Taylor] I feel
like I've known
that I'm mean to
do something big.
- Me too.
- [Taylor] And I grew up in
an entrepreneurial household.
- Me too.
- [Taylor] So it's in my blood,
it's in my bones.
- Good.
- [Taylor] I feel like I watch
all these other
Millennials hitting
these huge I guess
milestones in their life--
- What milestones?
- [Taylor] Then
I'm sitting here.
- Let's break it down.
How old are you?
- [Taylor] I'm 22,
about to be 23.
- Okay, what
milestone, please give
me a Millennial
and the milestone
they achieved
that makes you feel
like you're just
sitting in fucking Buffalo?
- [Taylor] Well,
I'm sitting in Buffalo,
which is one thing
I'm not happy about.
But--
- That's right 'cause
it's home of the Buffalo Bills,
piece of shit team.
- [Taylor] Yeah. (laughs)
- But before you go there,
forget about sitting in Buffalo,
who's the Millennial
and what's the milestone
that's making you feel
like you're sitting there?
Go.
The truth, go.
- [Taylor] Well
honestly there's people
on social media which definitely
is not always true--
- Who?
- [Taylor] But I watch,
oh god, the only thing
on the spot I can
think of is a Kardashian
or a Jenner which is
lame, but. (laughing)
- Can we talk about this please?
- [Taylor] Yeah,
I feel like, sure.
- Like you're telling me
that Kylie Jenner's fucking
trillion followers on Instagram
makes you feel like
you're just sitting there?
- [Taylor] No, I feel
like the fact
that she's
already got a business
started that's super successful,
obviously that
comes with her fame.
- Did you
factor in the fact that
her sisters and mom architected
something for 10 years while
she was a teenager that she
was able to walk directly into,
that gave her a springboard?
That she had the
financial capabilities
of deploying ungodly
amounts of plastic surgery,
and all the other variable
things that she's been able
to do to create that culture,
and that financial benefit?
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- Did you factor in that her mom
is a ninja architect of business
and created that framework?
- [Taylor] Yeah and I feel like
not many people give
them the credit for that.
- I agree.
- [Taylor] I totally think that
they built this empire.
- I agree.
But what the fuck does
that have to do with you?
- [Taylor] It has
nothing to do with me.
I know.
- No shit.
Remember how I?
I don't know if you
saw this where I said
stop looking at
your friends' shit
or whatever the
fuck I put on Instagram?
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- I don't know if you saw it
or not but it doesn't matter.
Like you looking
at the Kardashians
is the most ludicrous horseshit
I've ever heard in my life.
(Taylor laughs)
- [Taylor] Well that's just
first one that can pop into my
when you asked me.
- Great.
Listen, we're here, we're here.
Give me another one.
- [Taylor] There's a
guy in London.
I can't think of his name
at the top of my head.
- I'm gonna stop,
I'm gonna stop you right now.
- [Taylor] Okay.
- Let me give you some,
I was gonna say fatherly.
I guess my father was 40,
now I'll give you some
massively older
brother, uncle advice.
You ready?
- [Taylor] (laughs) Okay, yes.
- Every second
you spend thinking
about what
somebody else has is taking
away from time that you could
create something for yourself.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- You're losing.
You're losing
'cause you're laying
in your bed looking
at somebody's fucking
glamorous photoshopped picture
of them doing something cool.
You're envious,
and you're jealous,
and you're impatient, and
it's crippling your upside.
- [Taylor] Yeah
'cause that's where
I wanna be and I know
I'm not there yet.
- You haven't done shit.
- [Taylor] I know.
- So go do shit that
actually gets you there
so that you earn
it instead of like
you dwelling
that you're not there
and hoping that's
something's gonna happen.
I don't know what's
going through your mind.
- [Taylor] Yeah. Well I guess
I'm hustling on the side
but I don't think
I'm doing enough I guess.
- You definitely
aren't doing enough
if you have
enough time to fucking
consume the
content of a Kardashian
and some boy in London.
- [Taylor] That's true. (laughs)
- Taylor, listen to me.
Taylor, listen.
You've gotta deploy patience
and you gotta love the process.
I'm addicted to the
process of the battle scars,
the setbacks, the
lack of, you know.
Taylor, I gave up my
entire 20s, all of 'em.
Imagine not doing
anything fun or going anywhere
for the next eight years,
including Saturday and Sunday.
That's what I did from 22 to 30.
Every day I spent 15 hours a day
in a liquor store,
thought about a liquor store,
built a liquor store, sold wine.
Like spent every day.
Like this last weekend,
don't lie to me Taylor,
what did you do
this last weekend?
What did you do
fuckin' Saturday and Sunday?
Tell me the truth,
don't bullshit me.
- [Taylor] Yeah, no
bullshit, I'm helping my
mom right now on digital media
and branding for her company.
- Lovely.
- [Taylor] So I had a
marketing meeting--
- Lovely.
- With one of
the people doing that.
- Love you.
- [Taylor] Then I also
have coming up--
- How much time did
you have for yourself
on Saturday and Sunday that
was not working every minute?
Tell me the truth.
- [Taylor] A lot, a lot.
- I know.
So that's the punchline, right?
Now imagine this.
- Yeah.
- When I tell you this.
You spent more
downtime on not your career
this weekend than I did
in my entire 20s combined.
- [Taylor] Oh shit, okay.
(Andy chuckling)
That put things
into perspective.
- I think so.
- [Taylor] Awesome.
- I think so too.
- [Taylor] Yeah, I need
to just get to it.
- Taylor, you need
to do me a huge favor.
If you really wanna
win and you wanna come
to New York in eight years,
and shake my hand,
here's what you need to do.
You need to stop giving a shit
about what anybody
else has and realize
that if you put your head down
and just work for
the next 10 years,
no glamor, no new
fucking car, suitcase,
jewelry, trip,
event, no Coachella,
no fucking new fucking sneakers.
Like fuckin' work,
you will have it.
Every time you care about one
of the things I just mentioned,
it will slow down
your process of having it.
- [Taylor] Okay so
in less than eight years
when I'm a millionaire by 25,
I'll come shake your hand.
- I promise you that statement
itself made me 100%
guarantee that you won't.
- [Taylor] No!
- Yes.
Yes, that's how this works.
Being a millionaire
at 25 when you're 22,
and you're dick shit,
and haven't even started
is inconceivable unless
you fuckin' hit the lotto.
What's the romance?
- [Taylor] Hmm, okay.
- What's the romance?
I wanna make, you
know how everybody says,
"GaryVee, when are
you gonna buy the Jets?
"In two years?" and
then I reply 20 years
I'm a romantic about the journey
and the process which is why
I'm actually gonna pull it off.
You're trying to be
a millionaire by 25.
How, Taylor?
- [Taylor] It's just
a goal I've always had.
- Why?
- [Taylor] Right now with what
I'm doing I guess it's not.
- That's right,
it's an arbitrary
bullshit thing
that means nothing.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- Wouldn't you rather guarantee
millionairship by 36 than
by doing long
term marathon running
versus doing a
bunch of bullshit sprints
that guarantees never having it?
And I promise you,
a funny thing
happens to your self-esteem
when you're 31
and not a millionaire
because you've been
chasing fast fucking cash,
and you're now six years removed
from not hitting your goal.
Your self-esteem
starts fuckin' with your head.
- [Taylor] Mhmmm, yeah.
- Listen carefully.
- [Taylor] I agree.
- I wanna buy the New York Jets
but when I
clarify it to everybody,
I want the
process of trying to buy
the New York Jets more
than buying the New York Jets.
Understand?
- [Taylor] Yeah.
'Cause ultimately
that's the end goal
but there's a
process behind that.
- You have to
understand, I don't give
a fuck about the end goal.
I care about the process,
the enjoyment of doing it.
You're not
enjoying yourself trying
to get to a million bucks
over the next three years.
- [Taylor] No. (laughs)
You're right.
- Oh I know I'm right.
I'm just sticking
on this right now
because I feel like we've
gone into this deep enough
that I might as well hold
on for a couple more minutes
to see if I can
actually pull you through
instead of you
just being on this high
of practicality for 36 hours,
and then going back
to Instagram
bullshit in 48 hours.
- [Taylor] I'm gonna
deactivate that shit. (laughs)
- No, you need to
learn to discipline,
to be able to put it
in the proper bucket.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
I just feel like I hold myself
at this pedestal
only it's crippling myself
'cause I'm not actually doing
the things to get there.
- Of course so you're
playing a fake narrative
instead of
putting in the actual work
that's needed to
actually pull it off.
Then what's
happen is you're living
a fake world to yourself,
but you know it,
which then changes your behavior
in the way you
interact with others.
- [Taylor] That's true.
- I know.
Like for all my bravado now,
I was real quiet in my 20s.
People made of
me, like, "You work
"in your dad's liquor store?
"I'm on Wall Street
making a 100,000.
"I got a BMW."
I'm like, "That's nice, Pat."
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- Do you understand the level
of disrespect I have for Pat?
Do you understand the level
of disrespect
I have for all those
20, 30, 40,
50-year-olds flashing shit
on fuckin' Instagram
with short term moves?
I can't wait for the
fucking world to melt.
I can't wait for all
these bullshit people
to get fuckin' hosed out
when the economy gets shit.
- [Taylor] Yeah it's
'cause they're short term
affording these
things that are flashy
but in the long term,
it's not sustainable
for what
they're doing right now.
- Yeah but meanwhile, you're
admiring the fuck out of them.
- [Taylor] I know,
it's a problem.
- No shit, Taylor.
- [Taylor] It's really bad.
- Taylor, you need to
start lovin' the process,
and the work, and the grind.
You need to
start respecting people
that are like sleeping
with like four roommates
and buying their
t-shirts at Walmart.
- [Taylor] Yeah, you know what?
I feel like I need that wake up.
But I feel like I need to hit
rock bottom and
have that wake up.
I'm too comfortable right now.
It's annoying
the shit out of me.
- I don't think so.
I think you're saying you need
to hit rock
bottom because it buys
you more time to
bullshit like you are right now.
- [Taylor] Hmm,
I never thought of that.
- You know what I mean?
Like you know it's not working.
You're just saying, by the way,
let me go complete
left field on you.
You're a
22-year-old girl, woman.
Like it's okay to
enjoy a little bit now too.
You've heard me say
regrets, I don't know
how deep you know
my content, but once
in a blue moon
when people ask me
the advice for 25-year-old Gary,
the answer is go
have fun, asshole.
It would've been
okay to go to Vegas,
or Acapulco, or
like do some dumb shit.
Do you know what I mean?
- [Taylor] Yeah.
I think I've had my
fun in college though
and now I feel
like it's time to work.
- No, no.
That's the bullshit
PR version Taylor.
The reality Taylor is
still fuckin' in that zone.
- [Taylor] Hmm.
Yeah.
- Don't beat yourself up.
Don't hold yourself accountable
to arbitrary bullshit fantasies.
Just put in work and enjoy that.
Enjoy eating shit,
and dirt, and bleeding,
and the grind,
and don't give a fuck
about what anybody else thinks,
why you haven't done it,
why are you doing that.
Have four jobs.
Fuckin' Wendys,
Walmart, your side hustle.
Work, train, learn.
Don't think
you're a digital expert
just because you're 22 and
you have an Instagram account.
Show me how much
fuckin' shit you've sold
with your digital
social media skills.
- [Taylor] Okay.
- Do you understand?
- [Taylor] No, I do.
Yeah.
- You're just completely
in the wrong game
and I'm holding you
onto this because you and 99%
of the people that are watching
are playing the same game.
- [Taylor] I know which is why
I wanted to ask the question.
- But you're look--
- [Taylor] I can't--
- But you're--
- [Taylor] I'm obviously
not the only one.
- No, you're the majority
and the massive majority.
The question is, you just need
to understand the following.
You can trick losers,
you're not tricking me.
- [Taylor] Good 'cause
I want honest answers.
- You don't need
my honest answer.
You know you're not
tricking yourself either.
None of us are
tricking ourselves.
- [Taylor] No.
- I just wanna remind you
that you might be able to trick
your Uncle Hal, and
you might be able to trick
your girlfriend that was in
your fucking college with you.
But you're not tricking the
winner when you're bullshitting.
Got it?
- [Taylor] Got it.
- So even if you're
posturing, and pandering,
and PR-ing yourself, no
winner thinks you're winning.
- [Taylor] Yeah, 'cause I'm not.
- I know.
Work.
That's the answer
to all these questions.
- [Taylor] Got it.
- Work, learn things,
do stuff, try to sell shit,
learn how to make money.
Work.
- [Taylor] Alright, I will.
- Was this good?
- [Taylor] Awesome.
Thank you so much.
- Can you do me a huge favor?
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- Can you email me in 30 days,
and don't bullshit me,
what's your Twitter
handle or Instagram?
- [Taylor] I don't--
- What's your
Instagram handle?
- That's fine.
- [Taylor] Instagram,
it's @TheFabulousJourney.
- @TheFabulousJourney.
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- Me, and my whole
team, and the entire
VaynerNation is watching.
- [Taylor] Oh shit, okay.
Got it.
- I'm gonna smoke
you out of your bullshit.
- [Taylor] (laughs) Okay.
- Everybody's watching.
- [Taylor] Okay, I got it.
- Do you understand?
- [Taylor] Yeah.
- I like your blue dress.
- [Taylor] (laughs) Thank you,
I got it on sale.
- I like that answer.
That's the best thing
you said all fuckin' day.
you said this whole time.
Listen, slow and
steady wins the race.
You're only
competing with yourself.
- [Taylor] Okay.
- Got it?
- [Taylor] Got it.
- Nobody else defines you.
Not me, not everybody watching,
not your mom, not the
fucking Kardashians, you.
- [Taylor] Got it.
- You can grind and
be patient for 10 years
every day and still be
nine years younger than me
and I would trade
places with you.
That's how amazing
having time on your side is.
- [Taylor] Yeah,
time's everything.
- So use it.
- [Taylor] I will.
- Good, see ya.
- [Taylor] Thank you
- You're welcome.
(sighs)
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering
them.
(hip hop music)